hello friends I'm Ilana and I'm not
wearing makeup but now that we've
established that with our lives we can
move on the [ __ ] is this it's right in
the middle right there
it's how did so someone pointed out to
me recently that apparently if you like
Google search my name or you search my
name on YouTube one of the autofills is
eyebrow tattoos
I imagine this happened because a while
ago I had a very public stalker who very
publicly was angry when I got my
eyebrows tattooed for the first time but
the thing that officially crossed the
line and made me block him off of
Facebook which is the place where he was
most active in talking to me I think
outside of YouTube was that I got my
eyebrows tattooed and I shared that on
snapchat he ended up going on IGN videos
which is the company that I work for and
if people would say something nice about
me he would reply to them and be like um
she got her eyebrows tattooed basically
he was incredibly angry that someone he
had put on an unrealistic pedestal had
done something to themselves that he
didn't like and that was the point where
I was like hold up at this point you
about policing what I can do to my body
and you want angry when I do something
you don't like I don't even know your
goddamn name so that was the point that
I was like this is too possessive and
too controlling and too overbearing so I
felt too manly deleted him or blocked
him from everything and he made a habit
of interacting with big portions of my
audience who would be supportive by
getting mad that I had tattooed my
eyebrows ultimately because he was a guy
who didn't like that I had done
something to my body but he didn't like
but that's beside the point
I do plenty of thumb [ __ ] to my body
that people don't like and I'm very
sorry about it but I think it that means
people are curious and have a lot of
questions about the process of tattooing
eyebrows which is not what it's actually
called it's called micro bleeding I just
say tattooing because it's the same idea
and I just got them done again yesterday
so I thought I would just talk to you
guys about the process because people
search for it a lot so clearly they're
curious also to any guys well girls out
there who might be interested in doing
it it's it's a cool thing that I highly
recommend because I love it so I got
this done yesterday
which means that they look a lot darker
and a lot bolder and there's some weird
shiny [ __ ] going on there because I have
cream on them than they normally would
if I get in a very close this camera
isn't ideal for it and my skin's really
shiny because I have moisturizer on but
basically micro bleeding is a process of
drawing or cutting really little fine
hair shaped lines that replicate has and
then filling them with ink I'm not
actually allowed to touch them right now
but on this side I do you know you can
see I still fully have hair it's sort of
a needle it's not a tattoo gun it's a
needle cut things that would look like
his that follow the natural shape of
your eyebrow of your hair and it fills
it in the reason that I wanted to get
this down is because I over plucked my
eyebrows when I was very young and it
meant that that patchy and uneven and
very very thin and so getting micro
bleeding just means that I don't have to
worry about filling my eyebrows in in
the morning because I'm bad at it and
it's hard to make them look symmetrical
and all that [ __ ] the process took about
two hours requires a lot of numbing
cream because when it's not numb it's
extremely painful I would say more
painful than getting a usual tattoo
because it's on such a sensitive partier
face I cry pretty much the whole time
when I can feel it but otherwise it's
just laying in a chair talking to a I
guess technician about what you want and
then they do the work of filling your
eyebrows and helping you pick the right
color that would match the actual has
that you have there and just sort of
tidying your eyebrows up but I thought I
would basically just vlog the next
couple of days to show you the healing
process so that you can actually get an
idea of what they look like because
again right now they look a lot thicker
and darker than they will when they've
healed because they actually like kind
of start to scab off like a usual tattoo
will before you actually get an idea of
how they would normally look right now I
think it's mostly because I don't have
other makeup on my face but they sort of
just look like I've only filled in my
eyebrows and nothing else but yeah it's
gonna be a pretty casual vlog join me
okay so we're on day four
I feel like this eyebrow is still
virtually exactly the same as a little
bit of flaking you can see up the top
down this one is definitely around here
especially
you can see a little bit of the color
difference because patches of it flaking
off of course you can't put makeup on it
while this process is happening so that
is a small period where it just looks
like your face is very patchy and flaky
but if you put makeup on it could risk
infection obviously if you pick any of
the flakes those scabs you're going to
lose pigment so you just kind of have to
ride it out I think if I put it in the
light you can see there's definitely
just like blotches that are coming off
there I'm also just at a point where
it's very itchy can't scratch it just
gotta get through it but I am very happy
with the shape yeah I feel like you know
with the how fine the lines are
especially when that's come off a bit
more they just look like Ilia wearing
makeup well they look like real eyebrows
that doesn't look thick and goatee so
it's awesome
okay so right now I'm sitting in front
of an extremely bright light so that you
can see them up close fully healed
eyebrows but also terrible skin this is
the West that I think my skin has been
in like a good year this whole month has
just not been kind to my face I've been
extremely stressed though so I would
imagine that that is why but yes my
eyebrows 100% healed and there is no
makeup on them at all right now
one thing worth noting about that is
that it is my only annoyance with this
is that if I get foundation on them I
have to wipe it off because it will look
like I've put it over the tattoos and
will dull them out basically so I have
to like get a q-tip or something and
just wipe it off sometimes I just use a
tissue or whatever else this one I think
looks pretty fantastic if I swipe
through it you can kind of see what some
of the lines are for the most part looks
like a brow with makeup that's just not
too bold looks like real hair especially
from far away I think they look pretty
much perfect this one is a different
story because this eyebrow was a mess it
didn't it started over here for whatever
reason this I brought kind of stops in
the middle they're supposed to start in
line with your eye line this one started
a bit over which means that this is
tattooed right here you can see the
lines but from far away again you
usually can't really tell well under a
bright light it's gonna look shiny
because it's
but for the most part pretty
unnoticeable but I feel like it's worth
showing you the comparison of this
eyebrow which was really oddly shaped
for us as this one and the same applies
to the top because we lifted this
eyebrow you can kind of see where some
of its growing back this pots all
tattooed so I've got my actual eyebrow
hairs growing back there but I wanted to
show you you know what most people won't
notice just so that you have the context
of what we've actually done properly now
that it's healed so yeah you can see it
looks light out it looks a little bit
Retta that again is really only gonna be
noticeable if you're looking at it this
close with a HD camera if I back the
hell up this is how most people would
see me I feel like if I pointed it out
you can probably tell that that's a
little bit lighter because it's not
actual hair but that's pretty much it
and sometimes I do just fill that in a
tiny bit just to make it equal but I
really only need to do right here and a
little bit up here so for the most part
but yeah thankfully there's no strange
scarring the very fine lines it doesn't
look like a huge block and I would way
prefer it to look a little gapi and be
able to fill it in with makeup then fit
it to look like it's me a paint on my
face but I'm generally just think the
comparison of how this I where I looked
before hand cut I can't lift it that way
can I lift it on this side to how it
looks now very happy with it
the only process is really easy there
was a period where it was itchy I was
having to put whiteman on every day but
it just sort of slowly organically kind
of flaked off I made sure not to pull
any flakes off myself I would
occasionally I know you're not supposed
to but it's hard not to when you have
something on your face and there is
definitely that awkward period where
your eyebrows are flaking that I'm sure
some people would notice for the most
part people probably don't look at your
eyebrows that closely but yeah that's
pretty much it for this weird video I
don't make a lot of content like this
but again if you such a lot of PS on
YouTube eyebrow tattoos comes up in one
of the most search results so I'm here
given the people what they want also I
just think it's pretty interesting
process hopefully interesting for anyone
man old woman who's thinking about
getting an eyebrow tattoo for example if
you're a guy and you have a skull or a
gaff was something that you don't like
in your elbows you can just get little
chunks tattooed you don't need to get
the whole thing done you can just get a
tiny bit filth in and I don't people can
tell that is it for me today everyone
let me know if you have
I will see you guys next time